thank you
[Music]
[Music]
bones and all is a love story it's about
two people that are not only safe each
other but really in love comforted by
one another I was moved by Lee and
Marin's story carrying something that
you carry shame with or can't quite make
sense of I was attracted this character
of leagues I felt he had figured out how
to gain the system to survive with this
condition
why'd you happen to bring me along
you seem nice
his biggest vulnerability his true love
is kindness so when he finds that with
Marin in those moments where you're able
to fall for someone else you look more
closely in the mirror I think what he
sees is terrifying
he felt that that character was a great
role for Timothy and of course we had
great experience doing comedy by your
name I was experiencing the beautiful
blooming of his path in cinema what was
your first timeline
it was a babysitter mine too
I think he's one of the most unique
performers alive today also somebody
who's so spontaneous
who's really inspired by what's
happening in the moment and you want to
work with people like that because
that's where you get you know the
special little things that happen I
think he's so heartbreaking and I think
everybody's heartbreaking in the movie
Timothy particular though the producer
on this film and had a very positive
effect on this film it was an
opportunity to get to develop something
for the first time getting to take my
experience and putting that into a
character that's how this works how well
works this whatever this is
he brings a sense of insecurity
tenderness that beautiful sense of
openness and impossibility that are so
strong you know I'm thinking about that
verse
[Music]